[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den sport
ein schönes tor von mir und das sind die
nachrichten themen von heute
noch um die kernkraft es knirscht in der
regierung weil die fdp auf längere
laufzeiten pocht und sich damit gegen
den grünen wirtschaftsminister stellt
sorge vor nuklearen unfall die lage am
umkämpften akw in der ukraine nennen
internationalen experten zitat unhaltbar
von der queen ernannt am mittag wird es
offiziell neue britische
premierministerin am abend umreißt sie
ihre pläne gegen die sich zuspitzende
krise im land
die energieversorgung über den winter
sichern daran arbeitet die
bundesregierung dass der
wirtschaftsminister dafür nicht die
laufzeit der atomkraftwerke verlängern
will das findet die cdu absurd und auch
regierungspartner fdp geht habeck
notfallplan nicht weit genug in
deutschland kommen derzeit sechs prozent
des erzeugten stroms aus kernenergie aus
den drei atomkraftwerken die noch am
netz sind den meiler emsland will
wirtschaftsminister habeck wie geplant
ende des jahres abschalten
neckarwestheim 2 und isar 2 sollen für
den notfall bis april einsatzbereit
bleiben christiane hübscher kritik an
habeck kommt von allen seiten den einen
geht der akw notfallplan des
wirtschaftsministers zu weit dem eigenen
koalitionspartner wiederum nicht weit
genug es ist aus meiner sicht
außerordentlich wichtig dass ein
wirtschaftsminister gerade in der
jetzigen situation die interessen des
landes im fokus hat und das darf nicht
der eindruck entstehen dass hier
parteipolitische überlegungen eine rolle
spielen die fdp wirft habe keine grüne
brille vor weil er nur den
kleinstmöglichen weiterbetrieb der
atomkraftwerke vorgeschlagen hatte doch
es bleibt grundsätzlich beim
atomausstieg stellt der bundeskanzler in
einem zeitungsinterview klar die fdp
blickt bekanntlich etwas anders auf die
atomkraft das ist völlig legitim jetzt
geht es um die energieversorgung im
kommenden winter er wird die regierung
sehr einvernehmlich handeln so scholz es
ist auch eine ansage richtung bayern
hier wo sie wie nirgends sonst
stromausfälle fürchten müssen gab es
zuvor scharfe appelle wir fordern den
bund auf nachhaltig dies zu ändern diese
einzelentscheidung von 1 habig nicht zur
entscheidung der regierung zu machen das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium wird an der
stelle eindeutig überfordert zwei
betreiber e.on teilt heute nur mit man
müsse ja becks vorschlag auf machbarkeit
prüfen denn kernkraftwerke sind in ihrer
technischen auslegung keine reserve
kraftwerke die variabel an und
abschaltbar sind ein plötzlicher großer
stromausfall wäre mit dem notfallplan
tatsächlich nicht lösbar urteilen auch
experten wenn die kernkraftwerke in den
zustand versetzt werden wie habe ich das
gesagt hat die brennelemente
herausgenommen werden und kein betrieb
stattfindet dann braucht es eben mehrere
tage um den kern wieder einzufahren alle
notwendigen prüfungen zu machen ein
stresstest der für robert habeck und die
ampel koalition noch nicht ausgestanden
sein dürfte
mit sorge blickt die welt auf europas
größtes atomkraftwerk das in der ukraine
immer wieder unter beschuss gerät die
situation dort sei unhaltbar warnt heute
die internationale atomenergie behörde
noch am abend will sie den
un-sicherheitsrat informieren nach
ukrainischen angaben ist in dem von
russland besetzten akw sapori cia
derzeit nur noch ein reaktor in betrieb
um den eigenbedarf für das kühlsystem zu
decken jürgen kehl und arndt ginzel
unterwegs auf ukrainisch kontrolliertem
gebiet zu einem der wohl gefährlichsten
orte europas das team von reportern
ginzel dreht aktuelle bilder vom
atomkraftwerks aporisk sechs
reaktorblöcke mit dem kriegsgeschehen
not strombetrieb schäden an
stromleitungen nach neuen einschlägen
melden die betreiber russland hält die
anlage besetzt und macht erneut kiew
verantwortlich
der letzten 24 stunden gab es 15
ukrainische artillerieangriff auf die
stadt in arosa und auch das akw sapori
cia
tierkreis dies postwendend zurück so
geht das seit monaten fest steht nur
dass geschossen wird und dass die welt
den atem anhält
inspektoren der internationalen atom auf
sicht haben sich die anlage ansehen
können sie sprechen nun in ihrem mit
spannung erwarteten bericht von einer
bisher beispiellosen gefahr
daher ist das dringend notwendig
maßnahmen zu ergreifen die helfen an den
atomunfall durch kriegshandlungen zu
verhindern das kann durch die sofortige
einrichtung an der schutzzone geschehen
eindringende auftrag an die diplomatie
experten warnen aber davor in panik zu
verfallen es ist ein risikoreicher
situation mit der latenten gefahr auf
jeden fall allerdings ist es so dass
diese anlagen vom grundsatz her gegen
mechanische einwirkungen wie zum
beispiel auch beschuss geschützt sind
das heißt ein einzelner raketentreffer
oder granaten treffer auf eines der
container es würde nicht automatisch zu
einem kerntechnischen unfall führen und
solange es gelingt die reaktoren
abzukühlen auch wenn sie abgeschaltet
sind besteht wenn es nicht die gefahr
eines kerntechnischen unfalls wie geht
es weiter mit europas größtem
atomkraftwerk wie kann es gelingen so
borussia aus der schusslinie zu bekommen
ja wie kann es gelingen so porsche zu
schützen johannes hano in new york in
zwei stunden tag der un sicherheitsrat
dazu was ist zu erwarten
also man kann davon ausgehen dass die
russland versuchen wird ein eigenes
negativ in den raum zu stellen dass es
versuchen wird abzulenken von den
ergebnissen des berichts dass man gerne
hatte entmilitarisierte schutzzone um
das atomkraftwerk brauchen wird russland
wird und so wird es erwartet davon
ausgehen oder sagen dass die ukraine
schuld an dem ganzen problemen sei man
brauche die truppen in dem atomkraftwerk
um das atomkraftwerk zu schützen man
habe das atomkraftwerk vom netz genommen
um den gau zu verhindern
ich hatte gerade von der stunde die
möglichkeit mit der ukrainischen vize
regierungschefin und dem ukrainischen
energieminister hier new york zu
sprechen hat sich auch danach gefragt
und dort hat man mir gesagt man kann zu
dem bericht selber noch nicht sagen weil
man ihnen noch nicht hundertprozentig
studiert habe der sei sehr technisch
aber eins sei klar russland müsse
abziehen wenn man die den bau verhindern
möchte es wird nachher möglicherweise
eine abstimmung geben im moment ist es
noch eher unwahrscheinlich aber sollte
der sicherheitsrat nachher zu einem
schluss kommen dass man eine art
schutzzone einrichten will dann muss man
davon ausgehen und das ist dann auch zu
erwarten dass russland das mit einem
veto gelegen wird johannes hano live aus
maniok vielen dank
atom experte sebastian stransky ist
gleich zu gast bei den kollegen von zdf
heute live um 19 30 in unserer zdf heute
app und auf den social media kanälen und
um 21 uhr fragt von tal ob in sapporo
ein zweites tschernobyl drohen könnte
zurück nach berlin im bundestag haben
die beratungen für den haushalt 2023
begonnen die regierung plant ausgaben in
höhe von 400 45,2 milliarden euro
deutlich weniger als in den vergangenen
jahren das finanzministerium will
erstmals seit der pandemie die
schuldenbremse wieder einhalten so soll
die dafür relevante neuverschuldung bei
9,9 milliarden euro liegen die
opposition kritisiert die pläne als
unrealistisch
im bundestag war heute auch ein
besonderer redner und ehrengast geladen
der israelische präsident herzog seit
zwei tagen besuch der deutschland sein
appell haltet die erinnerung an die
ermordung der juden im
nationalsozialismus weiter wach andreas
huppert berichtet
ein gebet für die opfer israels
staatspräsident herzog gedenkt auf dem
gelände des ehemaligen
konzentrationslagers
bergen belsen der zehntausenden
häftlinge die hier von den nazis
ermordet wurde ein erinnern und gedenken
mit engen familiären bezug sein vater
herzog gehörte 1945 den britischen
streitkräften an die das kz befreit
diese erlebnisse der befreiung die
schildert herzog am morgen in seiner
rede vor dem bundestag
ich werde nie die worte meines vaters
vergessen mit denen er mir das grauen
beschrieb den gestank die skelette in
häftlingskleidung die leichenberge die
zerstörung die hölle auf erden
herzog würde ich die deutschen
anstrengungen die erinnerung an die nazi
verbrechen wachzuhalten israel sei stolz
auf diese partnerschaft mit deutschland
wir müssen antisemitismus und rassismus
den kampf ansagen entschieden eindeutig
kompromissen
bundestagspräsidentin verspricht in
diesem kampf nicht nachzulassen
antisemitismus ist nicht nur ein problem
der vergangenheit nicht nur ein problem
der anderen der extremisten
antisemitismus ist mitten unter uns in
der mitte der gesellschaft
drei tage staatsbesuch von isaac herzog
in deutschland ein besuch ganz im
zeichen von erinnerung und gedenkt
jetzt zu corona fliegen ohne maske ab
oktober soll das auch in deutschland
wieder möglich sein so wie jetzt schon
in vielen anderen ländern auf initiative
der fdp hat die koalition die masken
pflicht im flugzeug aus dem neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz gestrichen am
donnerstag stimmt der bundestag darüber
ab die pläne für eine ffp zwei masken
pflicht in zügen bleiben bestehen sie
soll dann bis april bundesweit auch in
arztpraxen krankenhäusern und
pflegeheimen gelten
gute nerven brauchten heute alle die
eine flugreise planen am morgen hieß es
dass den lufthansa-piloten morgen und
übermorgen streiken am nachmittag kamen
dann entwarnung kein streik am
verhandlungstisch sei eine lösung
gefunden worden markus wolsiffer am
flughafen in frankfurt worauf hat man
sich geeinigt
ja die details sind tatsächlich noch
völlig unklar wir haben explizit
nachgefragt bei cockpit und bei der
lufthansa und da hieß es im laufe des
abends also in diesen minuten in diesen
stunden werde weiter ausverhandelt und
dann ist vielleicht im laufe des abends
vielleicht mit einem ergebnis zu rechnen
dann sind erst die details bekannt das
war tatsächlich heute eine hängepartie
für viele reisende erst hieß es gegen
mittag um 12 uhr soll bekanntgegeben
werden wie es weitergeht aber erst nach
14 uhr war klar der streik ist
abgewendet insgesamt ist die
zufriedenheit über diesen abgewendeten
streik natürlich groß die leute können
es kaum erwarten den urlaub zu fliegen
ihrer reise anzutreten aber auch hier
beim bodenpersonal bei der lufthansa ist
die freude groß dass der streik
abgewendet wurde eine mitarbeiterin hat
hier ein kleines freudentänzchen
aufgeführt sie jetzt gesagt andernfalls
hätte sie morgen viel frust erlebt
freudentänzchen am flughafen fiel schön
danke schön markus wolsiffer
großbritannien wird zum dritten mal von
einer frau regiert die queen ernannte
die bisherige außenministerin list rus
zur neuen premierministerin von
vorgänger boris johnson ärzte jede menge
probleme rasant steigende preise
energiekrise und wechselt chaos
interessant war heute was sie dagegen
tun will andreas stamm
der weg zur macht führt nur über die
queen verlässt es ein weiter weg
erstmals nennt elisabeth dietz weiter
eine regierungschefin dem schottischen
balmoral gesundheitliche probleme
verhindern die reise der königin nach
london dort zurück auf dem weg zum
amtssitz downing street beherrschen die
explodierenden energiepreise die stunde
null von trusts amtszeit die aussichten
für sie so mies wie das wetter drei
millionen briten könnten die
energiekosten in die armut treiben
dreimal so hohe rechnungen für betriebe
gefährden hunderttausende arbeitsplätze
noch in dieser woche werden wir handeln
was die energiekosten angeht und wie wir
unsere energieversorgung in zukunft
sichern der sturm markt stark sein aber
die briten sind stärker
keine details wenig enthusiasmus und
kaum vertrauensvorschuss in einer
umfrage befürchten mehr als die hälfte
der briten trasse werde eine schlechte
regierungschefin
letzteres ist jemand dem ich nicht
vertrauen würde es geht hier eher darum
parolen zu verbreiten als effektive
maßnahmen anzugehen die den ärmsten
helfen könnten
sie regelt darüber die energie krise
anzugehen und das ist ja auch wichtig
aber mein grundgefühl ist alles ein
wenig hoffnungslos
schon am morgen hatte der mit dem viel
vertrauen und hoffnung in die politik
verloren ging und bei gesagt es sei die
eine ausgebrannte raketenstufe so boris
johnson und hinterlässt seiner
nachfolgerin auch ein kollabieren des
gesundheitssystem oder den ungelösten
drexhage streit mit brüssel die große
hoffnung von tinas eine umgerechnet 150
milliarden euro teure energie not preis
bremse soll die bürger milder stimmen
die trüben aussichten vertreiben
pakistan gehört zu den ländern die am
stärksten vom klimawandel betroffen sind
im moment erlebt das land eine der
schlimmsten naturkatastrophen seiner
geschichte
weite teile pakistans stehen unter
wasser vor allem die provinz sindh die
fluten können nicht abfließen auch weil
es nicht genug überflutungsflächen gibt
mehr als 33 millionen menschen sind
betroffen unzählige auf der flucht
normen odenthal
pakistans armee kennt derzeit vor allem
einen feind wasser rund um die uhr sind
helikopter in der luft auf der suche
nach kleinen inseln die die flut
gelassen hat inseln auf denen menschen
aus haaren die versorgt werden müssen
mit allem weil ihnen nichts geblieben
ist
pirani bibi ist 96 jahre alt das ganze
hab und gut hat ihre familie verloren
aber sie leben
ich bin gerade noch davon gekommen es
war knapp denn das wasser kam wie ein
reißender fluss es hat mich weggerissen
wir alle wären fast atom
von nord nach süd schießt das wasser von
den bergen richtung meer die provinz
sindh ist nicht wiederzuerkennen
sagt hat ein boot aufgetrieben einer von
vielen freiwilligen die helfen wollen
und überall finden sie welche die es
allein nicht geschafft hätten
vor vier tagen sind wir hier noch mit
unseren autos auf der straße gefahren
jetzt ist hier nichts als wasser
inzwischen haben meine freunde und ich
mit unserem boden fast 1200 menschen
gerettet auch wer halbwegs trockenen
boden unter den füßen hat ist nicht
sicher die versorgung läuft schleppend
mit nahrungsmitteln medikamenten so
breiten sich in den notlagern
krankheiten aus cholera malaria kratzer
und da ist ja noch mehr ein immenser
sozialer schaden so viele menschen sind
traumatisiert vor allem diejenigen die
geliebte angehörige verloren haben ihre
kinder
fast 1300 tote sind bisher gezählt ein
drittel kinder und keiner weiß was die
braune flut schreckliches preisgibt wenn
sie endlich wieder verschwindet
wenn sie den menschen helfen wollen
können sie das tun über das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe pakistan weitere
infos finden sie auf spenden zdf.de oder
im zdf textseite
prominenter besuch heute in düsseldorf
der britische prinz harry und seine frau
herzogin mccann gaben sich die ehre das
paar wirbt für die invictus games das
ist ein sport wettbewerb für soldaten
und veteranen die im einsatz verletzt
wurden die paralympischen wettkämpfe
werden im kommenden jahr in düsseldorf
ausgetragen prinz harry hatte sie nach
seinem eigenen kriegseinsatz in
afghanistan ins leben gerufen
und vom prinzen jetzt zur königsklasse
im fussball norbert champions league
geht wieder los und erstmals sind fünf
deutsche mannschaft mit der bei der bvb
und leipzig die spielen heute abend und
morgen feiern die frankfurter er die
bühnen der königsklasse und wollen
natürlich auch im ersten sieg feiern zu
hause gegen sporting lissabon
jetzt wollen die europäer auf die
königsklasse von sich begeistern
wir können uns jetzt im
größten im höchsten europäischen
pokalwettbewerb messen eine eintrag noch
mit zwei gesichtern in dieser saison dem
1 6 gegen bayern folgt einen monat
später das spiel zu null gegen leipzig
wir wollen diese energie die jetzt schon
jetzt paar wochen schon da ist einfach
auch ins spiel mitnehmen die devise
nicht so sehr auf die hymne
konzentrieren vielmehr auf den gegner
lissabon was mich überrascht hat muss
ich so sagen ist die intensität wie sie
attackieren im angriffs pressing sehr
sehr aggressiv die frage im
premierenstück der eintracht wie gut ist
der europa league-sieger wirklich
und alle tore alle spiele
zusammengefasst bei uns im zdf morgen 23
uhr im sportstudio champions league bei
den us open ist nach titelverteidiger
daniel medwedew auch ein weiterer top
spieler ausgeschieden nämlich rafael
nadal ja und war den frauen hat juli
niemeyer als letzte deutsche im turnier
ihr achtelfinale gegen england verloren
juli niemeyer beherrscht den ersten satz
gegen die weltranglisten erste aus polen
hier unten im bild aufschlag lange bälle
alles passt 6 zu 2 für die
dortmunderinnen doch das niveau kann sie
nicht halten die führung übernimmt das
kommando und gewinnt die nächsten beiden
sätze 6 zu 4 und 6 zu 0 das aus für
julia niemeyer zwei monate nach ihrem
viertelfinaleinzug in mündeten das
turnier in new york geht ohne deutsche
beteiligung weiter
weltumsegler und globestar boris
herrmann hat in hamburg sein neues
scheer vorgestellt begleitet von 70
toten und tausenden fans am ufer der
hafencity wurde die rennyacht auf den
namen maliziös explorer getauft aber es
bedurfte zwei versuche bis die
champagnerflasche am bug zerschellte mit
dem schiffl hermann 2024 auch an der
nächsten einhand weltumseglung worden
die globe teilen
doch die bilder von der härtesten
segelregatta der welt freue ich mich
schon jetzt danke schön für das board
von west nach ost ziehen schauer und
gewitter über deutschland die details
hat gleich katja horneffer marietta
slomka begrüßt sie um viertel vor zehn
im heute-journal und hier übernimmt
morgen jana park ist danke für interesse
einen schönen abend noch und auch bald
[Musik]
guten abend heute zogen schon einige
schauer und gewitter über uns hinweg das
sehen sie an der blauen und an der lila
farbe für viele gab es aber wieder einen
sehr sonnigen tag aber jetzt brodelt es
wieder in der atmosphäre und aus der
schweiz heraus und auch aus frankreich
her kommen neue schauer und gewitter in
den westen deutschlands und diese
schauer und gewitter werden sich im
laufe der nacht weiter nach norden
ausweichen auch die nordseeküste
erreichen und auch das allgäu hier im
südosten bewegt sich auch mal nebel die
temperaturen sinken in der osthälfte auf
14 bis 11 grad im westen bleibt es bei
17 bis 15 grad milder und morgen
erwarten uns höchsttemperaturen zwischen
20 grad in nordfriesland und maximal 27
grad am rhein schauer und gewitter der
nacht ziehen morgen ganz allmählich
weiter nach osten das können unwetter
seien also gewitter die mit starkregen
verbunden sind den äußersten nordosten
werden schauer und gewitter morgen wohl
noch nicht erreicht und hinter schauern
und gewittern lockern die wolken schon
wieder auf da gibt es dann nur kleinere
regenschauer der dringend benötigte
regen kommt dann am donnerstag auch im
nordosten an bis zum wochenende können
so 20 bis 60 liter regen pro
quadratmeter zusammenkommen guten abend